pour soir les enfants
on a bien failli être en retard ce soir
nounours a voulu faire un achat j'ai
acheté repos papier pour faire des
avions à nicolas l'a pas preneur et bien
descend vite les voir nous nous ferons
le joueur ou x de son patron bon et bien
frotter les d'un nicolas oui mais bien
frotter pape rhône elle ou ou une
surprise pour les enfants ça n'est pas
les a pas propre on est propre nom oui
vous sentez vos regards des papiers
c'est pour quoi faire pour faire des
avions
des aéroplanes vous allez voir là
je coupe mon papier en quarts et je le
dise en quatre encore en 4 et voilà dix
dans jal et il est à toi nicolas ménard
en voilà un
buchta preuve
merci morse ou ben moi je peux renvoyer
avec mon avion
[Musique]
washing nous à bientôt
à tour du bois je m'en fais un aussi
je montre mon avion iranien évoque
encore plus haut
alou douche à poil
venir à toi
[Musique]
aéroplan vous venu les enfants on va se
mettre en escales dribble derrière moi
tous les deux voilà chers
attention au monde
sous les marques de commerce
[Musique]
vous semblez
attention on le tue
[Musique]
couper les gaz et bois la ballon les
aviateurs au dodo moi j'ai pris froid
d'un ciel on a fait un beau voyage
[Musique]
oh
l'on dormait vite
grand voyageur espace sa fatigue
bonne nuit mon north à demain bonne nuit
les petits
j'étale alain
fait deux tours
c'est très amusant ses voyages mais
maintenant il faut vite aller se coucher
à te voilà aviateurs aussant rome a trop
oui mon bon nounours bonne nuit les
enfants faute de bourret adobe
[Musique]